LOSSES IN THE EAST.
ONLY 10% MILITARY ASSISTANCE
REQUESTED FROM THE WEST HAS
ARRIVED.
RUSSIA HAS AMASSED A SIGNIFICANT
ARTILLERY ADVANTAGE.
ALSO TONIGHT THERE IS CONFUSION
OVER THE WHEREABOUTS OF RUSSIAN
DISSIDENT ALEKSEY NA VALUABLE
KNEE, PRESIDENT PUTIN'S MOST
OUTSTANDING CRITIC.
THEY TRIED TO VISIT HIM TODAY AT
THE PENAL COLONY.
THEY WERE TOLD HE'S NO LONGER
THERE.
ONE OF NAVALNY'S LAWYERS TELL
CNN THAT THEY BELIEVE HE WAS
TRANSFERRED TO A HIGHER SECURITY
PRISON, BUT THEY DON'T KNOW FOR
CERTAIN WHICH PRISON.
NO ONE HAS CONFIRMED ONE
POSSIBLE DESTINATION MENTIONED
BY RUSSIAN STATE MEDIA.
JOIN US IS MARIA PEPCHICK WHO IS
HELPING TO RUN NAVALNY'S PRISO
N
PRISON
SENTENCE.
>> CAN YOU TELL US WHERE NAVALNY
IS?
>> NO ONE KNOWS WHERE HE IS AT
THE MOMENT.
>> THEY SAID THEY MOVED HIM TO
ANOTHER PRISON IN THE COUNTRY.
YOU SAY YOU DON'T KNOW WHERE HE
IS, SO DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
REPORTING?
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S ACCURATE
TO REFER TO THE RUSSIAN STATE
MEDIA.
THEY ARE VERY, YOU KNOW,
SPECIFIC TO CERTAIN TYPES OF
OUTLETS THAT REPORT THIS.
THEY HAVE BEEN WRONG BEFORE, AND
WE KNOW THAT SOMETIMES THEY CAN
BE JUST ASKED TO REPORT WHAT
THEY WANT THE STATES TO BELIEVE
IN.
WE ARE NOT RELYING ON THIS
INFORMATION UNTIL WE HEAR
SOMETHING OFFICIALLY, UNTIL WE
GET NOTIFIED, UNTIL NAVALNY HAS
BEEN MOVED AND THIS IS WHERE WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO FIND HIM.
SO WE DO NOT RELY ON THIS
INFORMATION.
>> ARE YOU OR HIS LAWYERS ABLE
TO -- I MEAN, IS THERE ANYONE
YOU CAN CONTACT FOR INFORMATION?
I ASSUME YOU OBVIOUSLY CANNOT
CONTACT HIM.
>> THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT OF THE
SITUATION, IS THAT HIS LAWYERS
AND/OR HIS FAMILY SHOULD HAVE
BEEN NOTIFIED IF HE WAS TO BE
MOVED TO A DIFFERENT PRISON OR A
DIFFERENT PENAL COLONY, BUT NO
ONE WAS NOTIFIED.
TODAY THE SITUATION IS THAT HIS
LAWYER SHOWED UP AT HIS CURRENT
COLONY.
HE WAS HELD AT THE CHECKPOINT
FOR A COUPLE OF HOURS AND
NAVALNY JUST DIDN'T SHOW UP.
THAT'S QUITE LITERALLY ALL WE
KNOW, AND THIS IS WHAT IS SO
SCARY AND HORRIFYING ABOUT THIS
SITUATION, IS THAT WE'RE AT
ABOUT 16 OR 18 HOURS AT THIS
POINT.
WE HAVE NO WAY OF FIGURING OUT
WHERE HE IS.
>> IS IT POSSIBLE HE'S STILL AT
THE SAME PENAL COLONY AND JUST
WASN'T PRODUCED FOR THE
ATTORNEY?
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S POSSIBLE
THAT HE'S STILL THERE.
HE HAS DEFINITELY GONE
SOMEWHERE.
NORMALLY IF THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT ACTUALLY HAS FOLLOWED
THE LAWS THEY HAVE WRITTEN
THEMSELVES, WE WOULD HAVE BEEN
NOTIFIED IF HE WAS TRANSFERRED
TO A DIFFERENT PLACE.
THERE IS A PROCEDURE, IT'S
PRETTY STANDARD, AND HIS LAWYERS
WOULD HAVE GOTTEN LIKELY WRITTEN
CONFIRMATION THAT YOUR CLIENT IS
ABOUT TO BE MOVED FROM PRISON A
TO PRISON B AND YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO SEE HIM IN PRISON B FROM
THIS DAY ONWARD.
BUT THE WAY THEY DO IT WITH
NAVALNY, IT'S A VERY KIND OF
DIFFERENT APPROACH THAT THEY
HAVE TO HIM.
NO LAWS APPLY TO HIM, SO IN THIS
CASE WE'RE JUST DEPRIVED OF ANY
INFORMATION, AND WE'RE BEING
KEPT IN THIS VERY UNCOMFORTABLE
SITUATION, NOT KNOWING ANYTHING
AS TO -- AND NOT BEING ABLE TO
LET US KNOW.
BUT WE DON'T KNOW IN A WEEK'S
TIME OR A MONTH'S TIME.
>> SO RIGHT NOW NAVALNY'S
REPORTERS JUST WAIT.
>> YEAH.
AS OF NOW, HIS FAMILY